The Pleistocene Park idea
that the Zimovs have been working on for 30 years
is that the animal biomass in the entire Arctic
and subarctic used to be a 100x greater than it is now.
It's basically depauperate now in ecological terms.
They're putting a density of grazing animals—
Yakutian horses, which you saw in the first video;
reindeer; buffalo; they're trying to get
some more American bison there;
musk ox; and so on.
Get them in the density they used to be.
They trample the snow which they need to do
to get at the grass in the winter.
That gets the cold down through the snow
to the permafrost, keeping it cold.
Grazers make grass that's how it works
in Africa; that's how it works everywhere.
Mammoths will not be completely required
to get the mammoth steppe back,
but it would help because elephants are good
at ripping up or knocking down trees.
That opens it up for other grazers
to come in and turn it into grassland.
That's a normal cycle the way it develops
in, say, the Serengeti in Africa.
The richness of animal life that you see
in those parts of protected Africa now
are like it used to be all over the world.
Including here. And including the Arctic and subarctic.
One of the reasons there's hope of getting the woolly mammoths back, once we go through this process,
is that it's wonderful habitat for them now
with the other animals to help turn it into grassland.
They are grazers themselves. And
if you get enough of all these animals back
you get the mammoth steppe back
which is grass which fixes carbon.
Replacing the tundra which is currently thawing
and releasing greenhouse gases.
This is Eriona Hysolli
from George Church's lab at Harvard.
She's looking very calm and studied.
But she's thrilled out of her mind.
Because this is a the trunk of a female mammoth
who was 60 years old when she died
some 10 or 12 thousand years+ ago.
Because of the cold permafrost and all of that
this is not a fossil; this is the trunk of the animal.
In a way the trunk is
the most elephant part of an elephant.
To be able to take hold of, wearing the blue gloves,
the trunk of this female mammoth from that long ago
was a personal connection across that time
to how it used to be
and to how it might be again when creatures exactly
like her can come back to that part of the world.
What she is doing is cutting off pieces of tissue
which she got from this and from another museum
and taking it back to Harvard.
This is one of those things where the Russians say, well,
there's a whole lot of rules and you've got to
get this that and the other permissions.
And it's basically hopeless.
Don't even think of taking tissue with you.
Would you like a plastic bag to carry it in?
We gradually caught on, that's how things work.
The answer is always "Nyet."
But there's a way.